ERIC ROBERSON: This song is on
the new album, which is called
"Mister Nice Guy." And you can
start it, because I want to
talk a little while you
play this part.
But the song was inspired
by my grandfather,
amazing, wise man.
And he lived in North Carolina,
in a little town
called Stokes.
And in that little town
called Stokes,
there was little house.
And in that little
house was a man.
And that man was my grandfather,
who would have
these amazing talks in the
front of the house.
And one time, he said,
Eric, I'm not
into hugging in church.
Now, he was a pastor in a little
church down the street
on a dirt road.
He said, Eric, I'm not into
hugging in church.
So I sat up and said, what?
He said, because I'm a man.
And if you touch me, I'm
gonna feel something.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: Now, now Lourae,
that Lourae in that
kitchen there?
Oh, I love Lourae.
I love Lourae enough to
understand that I'm a man.
So Eric, sometimes it's just
better to just shake her hand
and walk away, because
it helps me, man.
I want to dedicate this song to
that one particular woman
in this room who thought she
had a shot with me tonight.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: Oh, I apologize.
Oh!
I can hear somebody in
the back going, damn.
I apologize.
I apologize for my silliness.
God.
OK.
Please come back.
OK, so can I stop talking?
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"SHAKE HER HAND"]
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"SHAKE HER HAND"]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]